jack flaherty throws his
fastball about 93 miles an hour on
average the slider
is really kind of the key pitch for him
that's his wipeout pitch he'll show the
curve in the changeup
but the slider for slayer for flaherty
28
of the time that needs to be sharp for
him to dominate
swaying and a miss he struck him out
that's how we start this afternoon
crowd comes alive on two and two
in the air shallow right late break by
williams but plenty of time to get under
it
and makes the catch and on the mound for
cincinnati to be luis castillo and when
he's right when that changeup is working
he is awfully good gonna throw a lot of
those change up to left-handed batters
there's just three in the lineup
edmond with a base hit into right field
just keeps on hitting
well this has been a story for castillo
on the other side he's had some rough
first innings
base hit dylan carlson nice piece of
hitting edmond
racing to third runners at the corners
guided it up the middle what a piece of
hitting i like the hitting and i like
the base running of tommy edmond because
he went to third because no one was
home cardinal camp first and third with
nobody out and
goldsmith that up with or not on deck
chops it left side that'll score a run
out at second
and safe at first one nothing cardinals
in the ground out by paul goldschmidt
grounded suarez the awkward stop
bouncing throw nice pick by vato
6'3 inning ending double play but the
cardinals get a run we've played one in
st louis here's joey votto 225
navado ground ball left side knocked
down by de young from his knees
stretched by
goldsmith and the out well the defense
got done there we talk about playing
clean defense there's a layout
smothers it wide throw and goldie with
his patented
boy it looked like he came off the base
but he didn't move
this is popped up
gold schmad makes the catch in foul
territory
nice play by paul goldsmith six up
six down for jack flaherty tyler o'neal
he's just off the injured list and he's
back in there again today
well hit into right center at the wall
gone tyler o'neal opposite field home
run
his second of the year two nothing
cardinals
castillo 28 year old right-hander out of
the dominican republic
swinging at a miss that's strike three
and the second strikeout for flaherty
and jack is going to lead off the
cardinal half of the third inning
and castillo change up strike three
that's the three
best pitches that he has located and i
can't remember how long
and it just happened to be to the
pitcher castillo looking right over the
top of the glove big deep breath pitch
to the plate swinging in a mess struck
him down
two strikeouts in the inning for
castillo winker on a nine-game hitting
streak
where's bat at 350. winker hammers that
one
that gets down in center field and the
reds have their first
base runner their first base hit of the
day and winker
has a baseball best 10 game hitting
streak
hot shot to third arnado to second
edmond to first double play
and it's an easy 5-4-3 inning ending
double play
ultra drove in the first run with a
force play ground ball out
castillo again to the plate and strike
three
called got him with a slider top of the
zone over the inside corner and
goldschmidt locked up castillo has his
third strikeout today
castillo pauses at the belt now the 1-0
pitch to williams
and a ground ball pulled novato at first
he'll glove and step on the bag for the
out williams is retired three unassisted
cardinals are done despite a two-hour
walk in the fourth
on we go to the fifth joey vado will
lead things off
swaying and a miss in a strikeout of
vato swaying at a miss he struck him out
sixth time he has struck out in this
series
and flaherty is up to four back-to-back
case here in ending number five
two nothing our score tyler o'neal will
lead it off
o'neal again out to center
at the track at the wall he's done it
again
goodbye two for two
two solo shots three
nothing cardinals here's dylan carlson
carlson singled in the first inning up
the middle base hit
two out hit dylan carlson second hit of
the day
drives in kisner four nothing cardinals
full count pitch coming to goldschmidt
here it is swinging a
one hopper to third blandino knocks it
down picks it up throws in time gold
schmidt's out
and the inning is over more damage done
though the cardinals widen the gap they
scored two in the fifth
let's need some runs in a big way 3-2
pitch
swaying in a mess fastball he has struck
out three of the last four
and five today watch out boy
now he's hit on the helmet boy that was
a scary moment
clearly wasn't happy with jack for that
just above the
ear hole no time to react jack clearly
not
doing that on purpose mike maddox out to
kind of calm him down you can't blame
him for not being happy about it
no time to react he's probably arguing
that if you're going to give a warning
you ought to throw the pitcher out of
the ball game for coming up and in
david bell is getting his money's worth
be the 12th career ejection for david
bell
jesse winker will be the first batter to
see
flaherty here in the seventh inning
winker unloads to left field
god as jesse winker
gets his in the red second hit of the
day and the home run gets the reds on
the board it's four to one
outfield deep straight away crowd comes
alive a bit
3-2 pitch and he struck him out
no argument from suarez suarez strikes
out for the second time today for the
seventh time in the series
new pitcher is jordan hicks the 2-2
pitch
and he struck him out on the inside
corner i think that was a 90 mile an
hour change-up
my goodness 2-2
smoke through the hole right side base
hit
naqlin connects farmer scores reds get
their second run
4-2 and the 2-1 back to him
stays with it goldschmidt catches it
landino
is out 1-3 and the reds are out one
run one head one error dylan had his
fourth double of the year
and here's paul goldschmidt base head
into left
carlson hesitated now being waved in
he will score and paul goldschmidt
gives the cardinals their fifth run of
the day and it's 5-2
we're in the ninth inning and the
cardinals go to the bullpen for their
closer alex reyes and the bases are
loaded
barnhart crown ball goldie will take it
himself and the cardinals hold on
they win it five to two and a weekend
sweep against
cincinnati